beheadings corruption dictators
assassinations human rights violations
and discrimination this is often the
visual that is painted about saudi
arabia by the western media while it may
seem hard to believe many of these
characteristics are indeed accurate when
it comes to saudi arabia but like with
most things in life there is another
side to the story for many saudi arabia
represents culture history values and
most importantly opportunity i know that
for many of us these positive attributes
don't even come close to making up for
the negative attributes
however there's millions of people who
don't quite have the same stance in fact
saudi arabia is home to the third
largest immigrant population in the
world coming in at 13.5 million people
only the us and germany have a higher
immigrant population not only does saudi
arabia have a large number of immigrants
but they also have one of the highest
immigrants to population ratios as well
saudi arabia's total population
currently stands at just under 35
million people which means that 38.65 of
the population is immigrants for
perspective immigrants in america only
make up 15.28 percent of the population
so here's the untold story of how saudi
arabia became one of the largest
immigration hubs in the world despite
their horrendous reputation
starting off with the most obvious
factor we have jobs most people know
that saudi arabia is filthy rich off of
oil but they don't exactly understand
the magnitude so here's some numbers to
put it in perspective the biggest
company in saudi arabia is an oil giant
called saudi romco that's mostly owned
by the saudi government contrary to
popular belief saudi romco was actually
the first company in the world to reach
a 2 trillion evaluation in other words
it wasn't apple
also if you think that companies like
apple and google make too much money
just take a look at this thanks to
elevated oil prices in the past 12
months saudi aramco boasted earnings of
nearly a quarter trillion dollars
that's literally 34 billion dollars more
than apple and google combined
also we shouldn't note that saudi
aramco's investors don't get to keep
most of this money like apple and google
saudi aramco has to hand over roughly
half of their profits straight to the
saudi government with such numbers
though it's no wonder why the saudi
government is so rich but while these
numbers are super glamorous the same
cannot be said about the lives of saudi
immigrants the vast majority of saudi
immigrants are from third world
countries that are there to do hard
labor this includes countries like egypt
pakistan india bangladesh yemen and
syria now this might be a bit confusing
why take all this risk and emigrate to
arguably one of the scariest countries
in the world just to be paid a minimum
wage well the reality is that these
immigrants lives in their home countries
are simply far worse
most of them are usually jobless and
can't even carry on daily life so saudi
arabia's relatively low labor salaries
actually seem pretty appealing to many
of them technically saudi arabia does
have a minimum wage of four thousand
realms per month or roughly a thousand
dollars but this only applies to saudi
citizens and immigrants are usually paid
less the average labor in saudi arabia
is paid 36 thousand reals per year or
just under 10 000
something to note however is that
companies usually take care of housing
food and other common living expenses so
it's actually quite possible to save
over 90 of your salary on an annual
basis also most immigrants don't stay
here for several years or decades they
usually come on three to five year
contracts save up 25 to 35 000 and head
back home where they now have a small
fortune take india for example where 30
000 american dollars is equivalent to
roughly 2.4 million rupees this amount
of money is basically impossible to
achieve as a hard laborer in india in
fact this is not a small sum of money
even for white-collar workers in india
like software engineers the average
software engineer in india i earn 600
000 rupees per year so it would take
four years just to earn 2.4 million
rupees if we assume that these engineers
could save up 20 of their income it
would take them 20 years to build up 2.4
million dollars now of course it's not
like these guys will be stuck at 600 000
rupees per year for 20 years but i think
you get the point for poor individuals
from such countries taking on a labor
job in saudi arabia is actually super
lucrative but this money definitely does
not come easy as laborers in saudi
arabia are often subject to loads of
atrocities
starting off with the lighter end of
atrocities we have overworking as a hard
laborer it's extremely unlikely that
you're only going to be working at eight
hours per day
more times than not you'll be working 10
to 12 hours for at least six days a week
for certain industries like the
restaurant industry these numbers even
go up to 16 hours per day now saudi
arabia does technically have rules that
are supposed to prevent this from
happening for example working hours
aren't supposed to exceed 60 hours per
week and there are limits to overtime as
well
but if we're being honest it's not like
hard laborers are gonna go and report
their employers for them they can't risk
losing their jobs or worse their freedom
you see it employers often confiscate
the passports of laborers as soon as
they arrive and the passports aren't
returned until the term is over this
ensures that these workers won't try to
run away or report their employers
before their term is over
this too is illegal according to saudi
law but that doesn't mean that it's
uncommon something else that's pretty
common is discrimination race and
gender-based discrimination is rather
common but just being a labor itself is
usually enough to receive poor treatment
while none of this is optimal if you
keep your head down and just do what
you're asked to you should be able to
complete your term without any issues
but for some laborers things take a turn
for the worst the criminal justice
system in saudi arabia isn't exactly
fair so if an employer reports labor for
some sort of crime the laborer is
basically screwed let's just say saudi
arabia has some questionable ways of
getting confessions and they usually
have severe punishments for even the
smallest offenses the ones that are
lucky are able to get away with a couple
of years in jail and a few hundred
lashes but the ones that aren't so lucky
well they aren't so lucky so it's best
that you stay on the good side of your
employer regardless of how big of a
douchebag they really are given that
saudi arabia is trying to open up the
western tourists and basically become
another dubai they have put more effort
into fixing these injustices over the
past few years for example they've added
stipulations that allow laborers to
switch jobs without their employer's
consent similarly laborers no longer
need approval from their employers to
leave or re-enter the country while
these are definitely good steps in the
right direction and if laborers don't
take advantage of these opportunities it
doesn't really mean anything also just
because it's getting better in certain
areas it doesn't mean that's getting
better in all areas for example within
the first nine months of 2021 41 kenyans
died in mysterious circumstances and
there were over a thousand laborers in
distress hearing all this you probably
think that only the most desperate end
up making their way to saudi arabia and
that's true for basically all laborers
in the country but there is a small
portion of immigrants that come there
purely out of free will and here's why
while conditions aren't that great for
hard laborers the same cannot be said
about educated immigrants like engineers
doctors nurses teachers scientists and
so on these skills are highly valued
virtually everywhere and it's no
different than saudi arabia
in fact 85 of engineers in saudi arabia
are expats so clearly saudi arabia is
quite appealing for white-collar workers
as well
now it's not like engineers from western
countries are fighting tooth and nail to
try to get into saudi arabia but the
same cannot be said about engineers from
developing countries saudi arabia
doesn't pay insane salaries like feng or
something but they do have white-collar
salaries that are basically on par with
most western countries take petroleum
engineers for example the average
petroleum engineer at saudi aramco earns
109 000 per year meanwhile the average
petroleum engineer in india earned 811
000 rupees or just about ten thousand
dollars even a top petroleum engineer in
india only earns four million rupees or
about fifty thousand dollars so when
these engineers are offered a salary
that's two to ten times more than their
salaries in india it's no wonder why
they take the deal also something else
that we should note is that there is no
personal income tax in saudi arabia for
saudi arabia it simply makes more sense
to tax a couple of gas companies another
two percent then try attacks millions of
residents 20 or 30 percent with that
being said 110 000 salary in saudi
arabia is actually equivalent to about
150 000 in america it's not just
engineers and doctors that are attracted
to saudi arabia either
they're also able to attract a bunch of
managers directors executives and
business leaders for example 18 of ceos
at saudi companies are actually
foreigners in terms of living conditions
for these white-collar workers they're
obviously way better than hard laborers
they usually don't have to worry about
employers confiscating their passports
or having to work 80 plus hours every
single week
according to most accounts it seems that
life for these workers is very similar
to how life would have been if they were
in a western country with the same job
there are of course a few local
differences for example you have regular
prayer breaks and you're not going to be
drinking wine or eating pork but for the
most part things aren't all that
different you shouldn't mistake the
similarities for complete freedom though
if you break a law you're still gonna
have a far worse experience than in any
western country but that's just part of
the deal if there weren't any added
risks saudi arabia obviously wouldn't
have to pay as much so professional
expats don't tend to stay here for
decades either but they do tend to stay
for longer than laborers
in the end a large number of immigrants
in saudi arabia just comes down to one
thing and that's jobs having a massive
oil reserve it's only natural that the
country has plenty of opportunities
across the board
for a lot of westerners these
opportunities often don't seem to be
worth it given the associated risk of
living in the country and the ethical
concerns of supporting the country
but for a lot of individuals from
developing countries they don't have the
luxury to make such a choice going to
saudi arabia and grinding out a few
years of hard labor is often times the
most straightforward way to escape
poverty now of course the same cannot be
said about the white-collar workers
while they may be able to earn a lot
more in saudi arabia it's not like they
would have starved in their home
countries either so they did have the
luxury of making the choice and they
chose saudi arabia i know this will
probably come up as greedy unethical and
immoral to many of you but everybody's
experiences and perspectives are
different and you can't really
understand the situation or reasoning
without having lived their lives but
that's just what i think would you be
willing to work in saudi arabia for two
hundred thousand dollars per year
comment that down below also drop a like
if you hope the labor conditions get
better in saudi arabia and of course
consider checking out our discord
community such as your video ideas and
consider subscribing and see more
questions that logically answered but
until then i'm hurry and i'll see you
guys on the next one